[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
a small increase in the unemployment
rate while pay growth rise is faster
than expected
prize rebound for the Chinese economy as
it opens up after covid restrictions
code of conduct for energy firms with
the forced installation of prepayment
meters banned for over 85s
plus the rise of AI how artificial
intelligence is taking over everything
from Healthcare to Holiday bookings
foreign
King live in our business and economic
news from the heart of the city now the
UK unemployment rate Rose unexpectedly
during the three months to February but
wages are continuing to grow at a faster
rate than expected according to figures
published this morning by the office for
National statistics there was also a
drop in the so-called inactivity rate as
more people returned to the workforce
well the UK's unemployment rate Rose to
3.8 percent during the three months to
February that was up from 3.7 percent in
the previous quarter total pay including
bonuses grew at an annual rate of 5.9
percent in the same period that was
unchanged from the figure for the three
months to January and better than
economists had expected meanwhile the
employment rate Rose from 75.6 to 75.8
percent thanks to an increase in both
full and part-time self-employed workers
the number of job vacancies slipped by
47 000 but still remains north of 1
million at 1.105 million while with me
now Israel rapal he's the director of
the center of growth at bus Consulting
Group Raul welcome to you I mean the
picture is really one of a very tight
labor market isn't it yeah well it's
definitely a mixed picture we see the
employment stats being strong so that's
good for the economy overall it's just
the recession is less likely but as you
say laid Market remains very tight
employment growth is high and while we
see in activity coming off which I guess
will be a positive it's not really in
the areas that people want to see you
know it's driven by students going back
into the workforce not by people no
longer being on long-term sick which
remains very high retirees remains very
high so I think you know it is a mixed
picture on the whole good for the
economy but really showing a tight laid
Market suggesting inflation may stay
higher for longer and also you know in
the long term is that going to hit
Supply and output yeah it's those wages
numbers that have really caught the eyes
and I mean I guess this is what the
monetary policy committee is going to
latch on to yeah well I think we've seen
a real evolution in the Bank of
England's view of the late Mark over the
past three four months you know
originally I think they expected it to
loosen quite quickly at the start of
this year with the economic Outlook but
actually the latest monetary policy
report suggests that they're starting to
think well actually it's going to remain
tighter for longer and wage growth will
remain higher and I think this will
reinforce that concern and so it'll be
interesting to see it there next
decision I think this really puts it up
in the area of whether they will
continue to increase rates so they will
be concerned by by that by that wage
growth the one sort of Silver Lining I
guess is that there is some moderation
in private sector pay so you know that
might give them a sense of this time to
ease and I think if you look at the bank
of England agents they are finding some
evidence of of sort of easing behind the
scenes but we're not yet seeing that in
the in the data yeah why do you think
wages growth has remained higher than
expected I mean is it just the fact that
there are these skill shortages in very
pockets of the economy yeah I think so
we did a survey of 1500 UK Business
Leaders at the start of February and you
know 77 said they were going to raise
their Workforce or keep it the same you
know which and that was when they're at
75 unexpected recession so you know I
think firms just find it so hard to find
the skills find the workers they've had
a really difficult couple of years they
also think any kind of downturn is going
to be relatively short or mild and so
they're very unwilling to lay people off
and not be able to find those skills
again so I think we are seeing a lot of
Labor hoarding across the economy and
that's really contributing to this wage
growth and and there's also all the
other areas they're competing as well
beyond just wage growth you know um
training uh improved packages were
flexible working all those kinds of
things I mean that for me has been the
story of the last few months not only
has the fact that the economy has been
more robust than a lot of people thought
it would be in the Autumn it's also the
fact that with inflation a lot of people
are just sucking it up whether that's
consumers to businesses everyone is just
absorbing it rather than trying to pass
it on or or better or pushing back at it
if you like yeah yeah I mean I think
we've seen particularly the you know the
strength of retail sales strength of the
consumer it is surprising that that's
continued given the level of inflation
and I think particularly you know with
the wage Rises when we look back at what
real wages have done over the past 15
years they've been almost stagnant so
you can understand now why people are
pushing hard to continue to see the wage
rise as they want but you know at some
point um that difficulty of that high
inflation where it will bite and it's
going to be interesting but you know
firms are being squeezed as well when
they see these nominal wage Rises and
you know the higher input costs and
profit margins being hit yeah I mean one
thing that is very clear from the ons
numbers is that the gap between public
and private sector pay is is ever
widening does that make it harder for
the government to hold the line against
these sort of wage demands that we're
seeing in the NHS well I think actually
in the later States what we've seen is
that Gap has closed quite significantly
um you know public sector pay has been
growing quite rapidly the last few
months and private sector has been
moderating a little bit so it's at the
smallest level in terms of the Gap since
I think the the start of the
um start since pre-covered almost
um so you know we are seeing that that
change and I think that you know that is
a result of you know what we're seeing
with with the negotiations and some of
the pay settlements in the public sector
so I think it'll be interesting to track
that over time but it may have a
material impact as things develop and in
terms of these negotiations you know
ultimately this is a lot about Supply
and demands and what Workforce is there
and public sector is like everywhere
else struggling for for those numbers
yeah you made a really interesting point
just now about the inactivity rate I
mean the government wants to see over
50s workers returning to the labor force
as you say it seems to be 16 to 24 year
olds yeah I mean look it's anyone coming
back into labor force at the moment is
welcome you know in terms of the size of
Labor Force we're still four to five
hundred thousand below where we'd expect
it to be
um so you know anyone coming back in is
good but I think the government is
really targeting those retirees who have
gone out of the labor force because they
felt wealthier and that is a really hard
Trend to reverse we saw some measures in
the budget recently but I'm skeptical
they'll really have the impact and then
the big one is long-term sick you know
the the backlogs in the NHS and and I
think you know people really want to see
those start coming down I think we're
the only country post covered that's
seen that massive increase in sustained
increase uh and I think the government
is really targeting those two groups so
while they'll welcome the students
coming back into labor force I think the
other two groups the ones they really
want to focus on and that will be how
they're judged in terms of whether
they're having the right late Market
policies I think all right gotta leave
it there really good to see you this
morning thank you thanks a lot
some other business news stories for you
now and the energy regulator off gem has
tightened its rules on when energy
suppliers can install prepayment meters
off gems new code says that prepayment
meters which are installed when a
customer is in debt to avoid them
amassing higher bills may not now be put
in the homes of those aged over 85 or
with severe health conditions the new
code also states that 30 pound credit
should also be given when a meter is
forcibly installed to prevent the risk
of households being immediately cut off
the drugs giant GSK is buying a Canadian
company working on a treatment for
refractory chronic cough GSK is paying
1.6 million pounds for Bellis Health
which is based in Laval Quebec the
company has been developing a product
called cambly pixent which GSK said was
a potential best-in-class cough
treatment well camdenly pickson is
currently in development for so-called
phase 3 trials which is the last hurdle
that a drug being developed must jump
before regulatory approval is sought
it's been six decades since the last
cough treatment was approved in the
United States and currently there are no
approved treatments available in the U.S
for patients suffering from refractory
chronic cough
now if you're having trouble deciding
where to go for your next holiday have
you considered using a chat bot to help
you decide or the online and app-based
Travel Service Expedia is developing a
tool that claims to do just that using
chat GPT to give recommendations on
where to go and what to do what Peter
Kern is the chief executive and vice
chairman of Expedia group and he joins
me now Peter welcome to you this is only
in beta testing phase at the moment I
think when do you anticipate a full
launch well we're still testing it but
it is out and available in English
language on our apps in iOS so if you
have an iOS phone uh you can get it now
in the UK you can get it in the US
Australia anywhere so in English we're
testing it
um and we're rolling it out we'll roll
it out to other devices we'll roll it
out to other countries and languages as
we develop it now the the demonstrator
video that you put out I mean it shows a
chatbot answering questions about travel
destinations and responding with hotel
information will there be more to it
than that over time well the basic idea
is that people can use chatgpt for
planning so imagine you want to know if
Paris is nice in the spring and what's
you know where you should go near the
Eiffel Tower and what's to do or what
hotel to stay at it's really a planning
device that goes on top of our app so it
allows you to essentially get those
kinds of questions answered and zero in
on your plan over time we expect to use
it in other ways potentially to help
service and other things but really it's
a separation between the idea of
planning using these kinds of AI tools
and then and then doing the rest of your
trip planning through our devices which
are enabled by lots of AI but not chat
GPT we use a lot of them so it's
complementary rather than replacing it
exactly right you're right and I mean
you obviously want to make travel more
personalized and this is a way towards
doing that what about data sharing yeah
we don't share the data so just to be
clear chat GPT can have their
conversations with you the only thing we
abstract from that is really if you ask
about a hotel or a group of hotels near
the Eiffel Tower and it and it
recommends three we will save those for
you and then you can go look at the
those but we're not taking your
conversation from chat GPT nor are we
giving them data on you as a traveler so
really again this is a way to get you
into Discovery and then we have lots of
personalized capabilities through our
products to help you find the right
thing at the right time at the right
price Etc one thing that I commonly hear
about chatbots is they're desperate Not
to cause a fence I mean to take your
Paris example I mean one thing that
would unnerve me about paris's law is
there's lots of pickpockets if I ask the
chatbot about that would it necessarily
light on that well I think it will
answer you know the chat Bots chat GPT
and other chat that will come along for
sure is taking the world's information
so if there's information on pickpockets
in Paris which I'm sure there are
articles and other things that have been
written it will give you that
information uh but again it's it's not
about not taking offense it's really
about is it answering a travel question
and one of the things we've done is
we've written our own algorithms to make
sure that the answers it gives you are
travel related we're not interested and
it's political opinions or it's love
life suggestions we only want to help
you make travel decisions so if you get
into a strange conversation with it we
will guide it back to travel and that's
that's our part in that and how else are
you using AI to enable what you do more
broadly yeah we've used AI for years we
use it to help you search better we use
it to show you the right pictures we use
it to create products like we have now
for intelligent shopping to help match
you with the right product or even price
tracking for watching flight prices move
and suggest when the best time to buy is
so we have ai and machine learning
throughout the experience and a huge
investment in the service side to make
it easier for you to serve problems if
something happens there's a cancellation
a flight delay so we've been using AI
for a long time but this new latest
version of large language models which
everyone's all excited about with chat
GPT and others coming that's a
particular kind of AI that's really
around the use of natural language and
that has a lot of interesting uses but
we view it as just another tool to help
make the experience better I'm more
broadly what are you seeing in the
business right now I mean clearly I mean
we've got a trading update from EasyJet
this morning very very strong demand
there seeing you must be seeing that
everywhere yeah I mean travel demand has
remained quite strong you were just
talking about uh you know inflation
worries and recession worries uh you
know travel has seemed to hold up above
all other things you know maybe a a
legacy of covid when people still are
now putting travel ahead of all other
things in terms of what they're willing
to spend on but summer demand is very
strong we haven't really seen a let up
anywhere in the world uh and Asia's
opening up so that's driving a whole
other burst of interest and and uh and
excitement so I think we're going to see
travel hold up relatively well compared
to everything and it and right now it's
very strong obviously you're here in
Europe and it's great to see but I mean
the US is is the real driver for Expedia
isn't it it's a real motion it's our
biggest Market yeah but the rest of the
world's important to us too and and uh
yeah I've been I was in Asia two weeks
ago Japan's opening up uh you know was
the first time the cherry blossoms were
available to the world again post covet
and all the hotels were full I mean the
world is really filling up and big
cities are filling up like London
American tourists have always been vital
for uh the European uh tourism economy
Americans back in force oh yeah I mean
Americans are back I'm sure you're
seeing it in the London restaurants but
uh I saw it in airports everywhere
Americans are back but I'd say Europeans
are back in in certainly in Asia you're
seeing Chinese in in Japan like
everyone's going back to where they used
to go as soon as they can and it's
really booming again so I think you're
going to see a busy busy summer if you
if you enjoyed the covet Summers when it
was a little quieter it's not going to
be like that absolutely but I mean in
terms of Chinese Travelers how quickly
do you expect them to return to
pre-covered levels we've still got a
ways to go um there's not enough airlift
between China and other countries yet
direct there are issues flying over
Russia still uh from the West so there's
some challenges that are evolving but
we're seeing lots of interest from out
of China into China we're seeing lots of
searches in China to go other places and
I think as the airlift comes back you'll
start to see a lot more Jenny so
probably the back half of the Year
you'll see a lot more Before I Let You
Go I mean the interesting thing about
Expedia is that you have an absolute
multiplicity of Brands I mean Trivago
Expedia itself verbo.com exactly do you
have too many brands well we like to
think we have a brand to serve every
need so Expedia is really for trips that
are big trips complicated trips air
hotel maybe a rental car Etc uh
hotels.com is usually for the quicker
trip I'm going to par you going to Paris
for the weekend need a hotel more like
that and then verbo is our other Big
Brand which is really for vacation
rentals for longer a larger group trips
so that's kind of how we think about it
we have some other complementary Brands
but that's our view of it that we kind
of have an app for anything you need and
we serve any of your travel needs and we
like to think we're the broadest travel
provider in the world and certainly the
technological leader which is what we're
trying to do with AI so
um so that's what we try to provide the
consumers and where's your next stop in
Europe uh actually I'm headed back to
the states after a long trip away and
I'll be back there and then back here uh
in June again well we wish you could
speak Peter good to see you this morning
thank you good to see you
some other business news stories for you
now and that's always hinting just now
shares of EasyJet have risen by three
and a quarter percent this morning after
the airline said it expected fully
profits to be better than expected the
carrier said this reflected strong
bookings both over Easter and into the
peak summer period EasyJet said that
during Easter it had been running around
1600 flights per day with 99.8 percent
of plant flights operating despite
disruption caused by striking air
traffic controllers during the three
months to the end of March EasyJet
carried 15.6 million passengers which
was up 35 percent on the same period
last year profits for the year are now
expected to come in at 260 million
pounds
the e-commerce group thg the hot group
has reported an operating loss for the
final six months of last year 496
million pounds that was up from one of
137 million pounds during the same
period in 2021 well that was mainly due
to one-off accounting charges and
reorganization costs sales during the
period Rose by 2.7 to 2.2 billion pounds
while the news come today after the
company which specializes in direct to
Consumer sales of beauty and nutrition
products said it had received a takeover
proposal from the private Equity Firm
Apollo
well on yesterday's program we covered
the start of the innovate Finance Global
Summit a gathering of major Banks
Regulators fintechs policy makers and
investors for a series of discussions on
the future of the finance and banking
sector one of the central themes is the
future of money and payments and the
Advent of digital currencies both
cryptocurrencies and those issued by
central banks like the bank of England
or with me now as Marion labor she is
the macro strategist at Deutsche Bank
Marion great to see you this morning
you're appearing on a panel later on
today which is going to be discussing
Central Bank digital currencies how
quickly do you expect them to become
commonplace yeah absolutely that's a
good question and today just to give you
a big picture A year we have around 90
percent of sunflower Banks which are
working on cbdc Central Bank digital
currency so that's a huge topic and the
question is probably no longer whether
or not we'll get cbdc but when
in the world we have already few
sunflower Banks which have launched
their cbdc so for example the biomass
Eastern Caribbean
Nigeria
China is still officially in Pilot mode
but it's accessible for for everyone in
China so definitely the question is no
longer waiver or not but but when it's
coming in Europe and in the US we are
slightly uh behind probably the emerging
countries if we have a cbdc it's not yet
decided but it might be in the middle of
the 2020s so probably 26 for for DCB if
we have one if we have one well it
sounds like you think we will I mean
will these currencies be able to exist
alongside cryptocurrencies
absolutely and I think the way we should
see it so there are a couple of reasons
why saltwater banks have been spinning
up their effort for cbdc the first one
is probably because cash integration has
been declining uh in terms of longer
Trend but also in terms of the shorter
Trend because it has been
very quick uh thanks to the pandemi to
the covet pandemic just to give you an
idea for example a country like Sweden
is kind of considered as a cashless
country given that cash represents less
than one person of uh GDP it's very
interesting though the the fact that
some countries still cleave to cash a
lot more I mean in Germany for example
it's still quite a cash-driven economy
absolutely and Germany is very well
known because German people are relying
heavily on cash like in Japan as well
like in the US but the idea of CBD is
more to complement cash not to replace
cash and central banks have made it very
very clear that the idea is not to
replace cash but it will be issued as a
complement of cash do you think that
central banks as a Europe they're all
working very hard on cbdc do you think
they'd like to stifle innovation in
cryptocurrency I mean we've had one or
two Central Bankers saying that they
they fear that it poses a risk to
financial stability for example yeah
yeah that that's definitely true and if
we look at what happened in terms of
research in terms of announcements so
basically software banks have been
looking at uh at the issue of cbdc uh
since 2014 so in 2014 the pboc the
certified Bank of China was the first
bank to look at this topic but the
research has definitely sped up in 2019
when Facebook did the big announcement
of Libra Gem and since then the effort
has clearly accelerated and of course we
had like shoe announcement about crypto
about stablecoin cryptocurrency Richard
peak in November 21 when Bitcoin reached
around like 68k does the pboc The
People's Bank of China gain any sort of
first mover Advantage from from
launching this so quickly
I I wouldn't say there is a first mover
Advantage but uh but definitely they
have been looking at this issue and what
is fascinating in terms of some file
Bank digital currencies like sunflower
banks have different motivation to look
at this topic so for example for the
pbsc I would say that the motivation is
more uh to find an alternative to Cache
physical cash because it has been a
cashless Society a cash Society where
people are using cash on a day-to-day
transaction as well but also for
financial inclusion I mean cbdc may not
need to be linked to a bank account so
it's one way to make sure people are
inserted in in the financial Society
yeah I mean it's going to be a
revolution in payments the fact that we
could be sitting here we can just bring
money to each other all day long to our
hearts content absolutely absolutely and
and the the Chinese Society is already
there and I've been paying like digital
for at least 15 years now if you look at
alipay with Chuck pay and most
transactions are digital in China
already yeah now what about
cryptocurrencies so I mean we have Brian
Armstrong from coinbase on the program
this time yesterday and there's been a
real rally in uh crypto values this year
I mean bitcoin's up 80 so far this year
what do you think's behind that that's a
good question and actually if you look
at the long-term Trend uh so today we
are around 30k uh for Bitcoin 30k
dollars so it's pretty high if you look
at the long-term history five years ago
one Bitcoin it was one thousand dollars
so yes it's definitely lower than at the
peak in November 21 but still 30 times
more than five years ago now if we look
at the the short attempt from what
happened during the covet pandemic price
search for cryptocurrency for for most
of them by the way but it was due to
Abundant liquidity uh interest rate we
have very low traditional investors we
are looking for additional yield
now we are in a very different context
in fashion is very high interest rates
have been surging
liquidity has been a low world compared
to what it was early during the kovid so
cryptocurrency price have declined
significantly but during the year they
have they have increased again
and it's very fascinating because I
would say that Bitcoin is probably the
the North Star yes uh terram it's
fascinating on what is happening uh in
town in terms of the term again it's the
second cryptocurrency in terms of market
cap widely used for all the use case
like
um D5 for example
and terram has been undercoming like
several upgrades since September the
March and this is the amazing thing
whenever we cover uh crypto on the
program it really polarizes people you
get people who absolutely love it and
say this is fantastic great you're doing
this and then you get other people who
say this is all snake oil it's uh it's
really not to be tampered with I get the
impression from talking to you you think
that it's here to stay it's it's a it's
going to be a permanent fixture in the
sort of payments and and cash and money
landscape I I think it's here to stay
not all of them because again we have a
lot of different cryptocurrency we are
like around 15 000 cryptocurrency
depending how you count them uh I would
say that Bitcoin and ethereum are
clearly going to coexist and they are
here to stay for most of them I'm not
sure all right that's a good note on
which to marry lovely to see you this
morning thank you thank you
still to come here on Ian King live
we're going to have a look at how the
markets are doing this Tuesday morning
don't go away
[Music]
of the tale of the most successful labor
Premiere and his name
[Music]
well it's a great story it's a great
it's operatic in in many ways in its
scale because you start with a basically
a sort of peace loving hippie he's an
Oxford he's got the long hair he's in a
band you know he idolizes Mick Jagger
and then he becomes as you say Labor's
most successful prime minister and
Landslide victories swept to a victory
on a huge sort of uh well of Hope and
excitement you've got the turn of the
Millennium you've got Brit pop you know
England is swinging once again and then
he has a little problem in the Middle
East basically I mean uh and the whole
thing goes it is a comedy I mean there's
a lot of stuff in that you think well
it's not suitable for comedy but in many
ways it's not about Tony it's the sort
of message of it is if there is one is
do we ever get the leaders that we
deserve and what what is your conclusion
to that well we I I can't uh sing you
the the final song because there are
rude words in it but we we're sort of
saying that a lot of we seldom get the
the leaders we deserve uh we tend to end
up with people who are um
well egomaniacs all the information's
there it's not a history lesson you know
we have got you saw from the clip
there's a lot of slapstick there's some
big characters from that time I mean who
who are we going to see in the show well
you've got Tony you've got Prescott
who've you know obviously a famously
punched a voter yes for that one you've
got you got David blunkett you've got
but you've got Princess Diana you've got
those real baddies you've got or you
know portrayed as bad he's Saddam
Hussein and Osama Bin Laden obviously
this stuff requires a very light touch
thank you
well the pound is higher on Foreign
Exchange markets this morning as though
stronger wages growth High than expected
raised the prospect of further interest
rate rises from the bank of England
Sterling currently ahead by nearly half
of one percent against the US dollars
more or less unchanged against the Euro
right now uh The single currency
meanwhile is up for two-fifths of one
percent against the Greenback well on
the equity markets Following last
night's gains on Wall Street last night
the Asia Pacific region saw mixed
trading over now that was despite news
that China's economy grew by four and a
half percent during the first three
months of the year that was better than
the four percent that had been expected
uh Shanghai Mumbai and Sydney all
finished lower while they were gains in
Hong Kong the Nikkei in Tokyo I mean
well that was a star turn again it Rose
for an eighth straight session which is
his longest running streak since March
last year Well in Europe stocks are
trading largely higher this morning
here's the current pitch all of the
Continental European indices in positive
territory right now talking points in
Europe today include Airbus it's off one
and three quarter percent in Paris after
it warned customers of possible delays
to deliver as a single aisle aircraft
next year we're here in London the ftse
100 is up a quarter of one percent right
now the mining heavyweights have been
shared by that better than expected GDP
data from China the Mexican silver Miner
fresnio is the leading Blue Chip Gainer
right now in percentage terms that's on
the back of some supportive broker
comment that shares up nearly four and a
half percent right now other bleeding
gainers in the ftse this morning include
the gaming group entain the shares ahead
by some two and a quarter percent on a
trading update the index as a whole is
currently on course for its eighth
straight game outside the foot seat
again there's an awful lot going on the
Outsourcing group Mighty the shares up
more than 12 right now that's on news
that profits for the year going to be
better than expected while volax the
power and data transmission products
group is ahead by some 17 for similar
reasons but the money transfer group
wise is off by 11 after warning of lower
transaction volumes per customer as for
the oil price well that sold off sharply
yesterday and it's continued to drift
this morning despite that Chinese
economic data Bala Brent crude will
currently set you back
84.52 cents about that is off a quarter
of one percent on the session but with
me this morning is Guy Ellison he's head
of listed equities at investec wealth
good to see you guy um we should start I
guess with the Chinese GDP number yeah
it's a very strong print from the
Chinese GDP for the first quarter they
printed four and a half percent growth
year on year the market have been
expecting around four percent not a
complete surprise those more real-time
economic indicators that we get in the
form of the purchasing manager indices
of pmis they've been suggesting that
both the manufacturing and the services
components of the Chinese economy were
uh showing a a rapid rebound once
covered restrictions eased at the start
of the year so perhaps the risk to this
GDP forecast was on the upside but to
see it come in half the percentage Point
ahead of expectations yeah a very
positive start for China and indeed for
the global economic Outlook yeah I mean
are you surprised the oil price hasn't
uh rebounded on this yeah yeah the oil
price obviously there are many
geopolitical factors Weighing on that
whether it's the U.S policy towards you
know its reserves and replenishment
there obviously what OPEC plus is doing
but you know you mentioned in your
introduction a much clearer transmission
through to the mining sector and those
mining names in London that are you know
significant suppliers of raw materials
into China all gaining this morning as
well but yes all else been equally
you're expected the oil price to have
been positive yeah now what about
earnings season I mean it's it's kicked
off in the US we had three of the big
banks on Wall Street last Friday
afternoon they're ticking through too
early to draw any conclusions oh I think
so it's been a good start but of the 500
names in the S P 500 that we'll expect
to update over the next month or so
we've had about 35 of those updating so
far including you know some of those big
Bellwether banks that you mentioned at
the back end of last week what we've
seen so far around 35 companies have
updated nine out of 10 of them have have
bettered Market expectations and it's
been quite a sizable beat of earnings
forecast around 13 on average so that
all goes well for the start of the
season and probably perhaps slightly
goes against the form that was expected
you know lots of commentators and
including ourselves have been expecting
a Slowdown in corporate profits to come
through at some point we saw them fall
slightly in the fourth quarter of last
year we had expected a contraction this
year and we may still get that in the
first quarter but so far bettering
expectations quite comfortably yeah it
is fascinating um I mean on that point
guy that we've had a rash of bids for
Mid caps in this country is that because
these valuations are just too bummed out
now people are looking at the earnings
potential and thinking it's actually not
as bad as we thought yeah I think you
know many commentators have shown a
spotlight on the UK you know over the
last months and years highlighting that
from a valuation perspective the market
as a whole looks very cheap compared to
uh International peers particularly the
US I we always have to be a little bit
careful comparing headline index levels
between the two different geographies
you know the composition of the UK
Market is very different to that of the
US you know the UK around 20 of the
stock market is oil and gas and mining
companies which tend to attract a far
lower PE multiple than the technology
that makes up 25 of the US but even when
you look at like for like businesses you
know Potter and gamble versus Unilever
as an example you still find that the US
companies tend to trade on a slight
premium uh to their European
counterparts so yes with the moves in
Sterling as well and private Equity
having you know plenty of dry money as
as Apollo's recent moves uh highlight uh
yeah we're not at all surprised and
quite happy to see you know a bit of a
spotlight shown back on some of the
value that exists in the UK Market I bet
you are and you mentioned index
composition there you've just done some
really interesting research on this the
extent to which individual indices are
dominated by heavyweight stocks yes when
you get down to the country level you
get some quite unusual situations and
this line of thought uh as a team was
triggered by the the move in lvmh last
week you know lvmh comfortably the
largest constituent of the French index
you know it was up five percent on the
back of blowout uh quarterly results
again another indicator of the strength
in China an important End Market fail
vmh but that move in lvmh which is
around 15 of the French Market you know
single-handedly meant that the French
exchange stood out against its European
peers uh on Thursday of last week as a
Gainer so that prompted a bit more
analysis into how concentrated our
individual European markets you know we
bemoan the fact that in the UK we've got
Astra and shell both around 10 cent of
the market you know in the US you have
Microsoft and Apple between them about
15 but actually that kind of
concentration is nothing compared to
some of the European markets yeah
Belgium I think is uh one of the big
ones Belgium where you have uh ABI you
know nearly 40 of their domestic Market
you know the top three and at least 60
percent you know look at that
Netherlands and the the great success
story that is asml you know 35 of of
that Dutch Market as well so you know we
think we have problems with a
concentrated Market in the UK but some
of those European uh markets are far far
more concentrated it's extraordinary a
bit when you came in you never thought
we'd be discussing the Belgian stock
market good to see you this morning
thank you
still to come here only in King life how
AI is being used to improve customer
service don't go away
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back now this feels like an
important moment in the development of
artificial intelligence or AI it's being
Incorporated an increasing number of
applications as we learned earlier on
this morning but it's causing disquiet a
group of tech entrepreneurs led by Elon
Musk recently called for a six-month
halt on any research on AI models more
advanced than open ai's gpt4 while Ian
Hogarth who's invested in more than 50
AI companies warned in the financial
times at the weekend that a future
Godlike AI as he called it could lead to
the obsolescence or destruction of the
human race in the absence of Regulation
well joining me now is the AI scientist
Dr Rasmus Rota who's also co-founder and
chief technology officer at marantinks
the company describes itself as the
world's first concept to scale-up
ecosystem for AI companies Erasmus
welcome to you this morning I mean it
does feel as though AI is is
developing at a rate of Leaps and Bounds
right now is this a more significant
moment than it's being given credit for
no it's definitely been a moment like
you described I mean like the last
couple of months has been like very
accelerating on the AI development side
and I think we will see more exciting
developments in the coming months and it
will certainly change a lot of Our Lives
similarly to how the computer and the
internet has changed the the working
environment so yes there will be many
changes and many of them will be for a
good they will improve you know Health
Care Mobility uh many areas of of the
daily daily lives but obviously there
are also some concerns and I think they
also need to be addressed well we'll
come on to that in a moment but I just
want to know why you think it is that
progress has exponentially accelerated
I think open AI with the launch of GPT
has really shown a new interface to
interact with the EI previous language
models were also already really good
like even a year ago two years ago but
chetu PT is just such an intuitive
interface that basically many people
could easily interact with the year and
realize how good it works and yes
they've been also some obviously
technical improvements in the last
couple of months that led to this
performance
how quickly do you expect every company
to have to incorporate AI into what they
do
I think every company should look at AI
as of today like it will it I mean it's
already changing when we think about
things about like writing texts or
emails marketing creative work so yeah
all the companies should look at it now
and yes it will obviously take a couple
of months and years until it's fully
adopted and you need to have it to be
fully competitive but I think like
closing your eyes and ignoring it is
just wrong at this time now Germany is
emerging as quite a Powerhouse in the
field of AI you've I think said on
record you want Europe to catch up with
with the US in respect to what it's
doing with AI how quickly can that
happen
so it has to happen I mean we've seen
that on the cloud computing side right
like where
um the large US tech companies have
really
um had a big advantage and are now so
far ahead that it's impossible to catch
up for any European cloud provider and I
think something similar might happen on
the AI side I think there have been also
behind and if we continue to do so so if
we in the next couple of months and
years are not heavily investing into AI
as companies as governments as research
will really fall behind and that will
make us very dependent on on other
continents in terms of running our
country ultimately
now you mentioned disquiet uh from some
quarters towards the the growth of AI I
mean I don't know whether you saw the
Ian Hogarth piece in the financial times
but uh this line about Godly like AI is
he uh over exaggerating
I think he's exaggerating but there's a
lot of true points in this
um you know right now ultimately the eye
all it does is basically processing a
lot of text images and data and then
creating a lot of text and images or
other types of data so it's still
somehow constrained in what it does but
obviously if you you could imagine a
system that someone trains them him or
herself that gets better over time that
maybe does things the human doesn't
fully understand anymore and I think
these are serious concern I don't think
they will cause problem in the next
couple of months but
um there might cause pretty big problems
in five to ten years so it's super
important that
um you know society as a whole thinks
about how to deal with it how to
regulate it what to allow what not to
allow
um and also how to prosecute it and so
we should start a dialogue I think you
should not move too quickly there
because it's such a complex thing and
even talking to experts I think nobody
really has has the solution how we can
best regulate it and deal with it as a
society but it needs a dialogue and it's
also good that this dialogue is very
open you know through press media and
and people are working on it but from
what you've just said I I glean from
that that you don't want uh regulation
to be to have it heavy-handed just yet
in case it stifles uh innovation
yeah I think that's that's the problem
uh we had in the in the EU before and
also in in the UK right that we first
tried to regulate and then
um later figure out how to build things
and and that is then much more
complicated and so I think there is a
few like very obvious use cases for AI
and Healthcare Mobility I mean there's a
lot of things that would run better in
healthcare and Diagnostics if AI was
used or in Mobility less people would um
you know die in car accidents so I think
these kind of very good applications
that are very high risk at the same time
should be allowed and we should make
that there is clear regulation and I'm
not for like more or less regulation I'm
for Clear regulation I think the biggest
problem for these concrete use cases is
if the regulation is uncertain
um and and people don't know how to deal
with it because that ultimately uh makes
investors skeptical makes customers
skeptical so
um I hope now that the as the UK and
also the EU are working on the
regulation that they make it as concrete
and clear as possible and there's still
some work to do to get there
all right Rasmus we have to leave it
there I'm afraid hope to see you again
in future it's been fascinating talking
to you today thank you thanks
now continuing the AI theme on today's
program customer satisfaction quite
often hinges on the level of customer
service received and not just the
quality of the product or service well
big companies including that Western
Vodafone Outsource their customer
service to Providers like genesis which
provides call center agents and which is
increasingly making use of AI the
company claims to have facilitated more
than 25 billion customer interactions
for organizations in more than 100
countries well I'm joined Now by Tony
Bates he's chief executive of Genesis
which helps businesses provide customer
services Tony good to see you this
morning
um how much more are companies spending
on this right now are you seeing a big
uptick in spending yeah we are actually
um we uh Genesis we do a survey every
year of sort of the spending customer
experience in the last year we've seen a
25 increase in that spend does it follow
though that voice recognition AI chat
Bots enhance customer service a lot of
people just want to talk to a human
being yeah well I would say what we see
in what we're focused on at Genesis is
really it's about a full
personalized empathetic experience and
so it's not sort of just one form of
interaction it's all of those forms and
making sure you do them in the right way
at the right time and so we're really
focused on providing that technology and
so I think a lot of what you've seen in
the customer service customer experience
space have been very business Centric
but the reality is that we need to
become much more people-centric as we
move forward how can you measure
satisfaction from the end user's point
of view which is pretty critical yeah
there are ways of doing it there's been
techniques called uh net promoter score
where you actually survey after an
interaction after an experience at
Genesis actually we have some very
Innovative technology which we call the
experience index so you really look at
it from three lenses efficiency and
Effectiveness which are important but
come back to what I talked about before
which is really empathy how did that
experience that real-time moment where
you either Delight the End customer or
you you give you know you give them a
reason to essentially leave and we
actually measure that on a constant
basis and then we use that to train our
engineering staff and our products and
then start to feed that back into some
of the AI and the data that we use all
right Tony bear with us please just for
a moment because we're going to go to
some live pictures that we're seeing now
from Moscow where a court is hearing an
appeal against the arrest and Detention
of the Wall Street Journal reporter Evan
gershkovich he is about to appear in
court we understand
very experienced report he's been in
Russia for a number of years originally
uh has Russian descent from his family
here though he isn't of course an
American citizen The Wall Street Journal
last week uh at the ante
it's fair it seems that uh they're not
going to allow cameras into the court
this is obviously a highly controversial
uh court case Evan gershkovic accused of
spying we understand that he was
actually visited in prison Yesterday by
the American ambassador to Moscow
um as I say very very controversial he
has been held in one of moscow's uh most
high security uh prisons it's a very
very tough regime it's some of the
reporting that the Wall Street Journal
has done on this has just emphasized
what a tough place it is we're
let's see if we can see what happens
there there indeed is Evan gershkovich
The Wall Street Journal reporter
foreign
we've lost the pictures there we'll
we'll try and bring you more on that as
soon as we have it obviously this is a
critical story on uh the freedom of the
press so we'll hopefully have more on
that uh for us as we go on Tony sorry to
uh interrupt you there I mean there are
an awful lot of uh players in this field
Delights of you and and Cisco and Avaya
what's the competitive landscape like
are you seeing more people coming in uh
I think we do see people coming in but
really uh where we differentiate is
really it's about not only
um some of the technology we just talked
about but really getting people to the
cloud uh you need to be really Nimble
and agile and we're really the leaders
on both the global point of view in
terms of that and we have been able to
transition many many of not only our
existing customers many of our
competitive customers towards our our
next Generation Cloud technology I think
if you're not focused as a business on
moving to the cloud you're going to have
a challenge here you're going to feel
you know you're going to sort of be
outdated you're potentially going to
really lose your customers one of the
things that we found last yeah we also
we do research in this area if we found
a third of consumers if they have one
bad experiments for the business they're
likely to abandon that business
that's pretty shocking when you think
about it but that's because in this
experienced economy that we live in
today
consumers have choice and they're really
looking for those incredible empathetic
personalized experiences all right Tony
I'm sorry about this uh do bear with us
we're going to go back to uh Moscow for
uh we've got some more pictures of uh
here is Evan gershkovich The Wall Street
Journal correspondent arrested on the
charges of spying by the Russians we can
speak now to our correspondent uh John
Sparks uh John obviously this is the
first time we've seen Evan gershkovic
since he was arrested
that is right yeah he is the I mean the
significance of this is that he is the
first American the First Western
journalist I believe to have been
arrested by the Russian authorities
since the cold war that is the the
significance of this
um the case today is around his
detention his pre-trial detention and we
can see him here in the in the Dock of
the courtroom he looks relatively
relaxed we'll be speaking to his lawyers
there but this is not about the
the substance of his charges that will
come later at the moment this is about
how he is being detained at the moment
he's currently being held in custody at
the a prison just outside of Moscow
called letovo La fertovo it's a
notorious prison in Russia where
traditionally political prisoners have
been kept he has been charged with
Espionage or spying he faces up to 20
years in prison if he is found guilty
and what the Russians say is that he was
caught red-handed trying to obtain
classified material about an arms
Factory in katrinburg that's a large
city in Siberia almost 2 000 kilometers
to the east of Moscow and he was
arrested on the 30th of March the last
time the newspaper that he works for
works for the Wall Street Journal heard
from him was just as he was about to
enter a steak restaurant weren't able to
get in touch with him anymore there we
can see him again he's in the dock this
will be before the case before the
hearing that he is about to appear in he
will be trying
to
I would assume his lawyers will be
trying to get an alternative custody
arrangement for him he is being held at
the moment in a prison called leffortovo
just outside of Moscow the Americans
have been struggling to get access to
him the U.S ambassador yesterday was
able to see him and said that he was
holding up his his spirits were were
strong and the U.S President Joe Biden
he has talked about this case as well he
has called
the uh the Detention of gershkovic as
totally illegal and the state department
the the foreign Ministry of the U.S
government they say he has been
wrongfully detained at the charges of
bogus and that the case is political and
it is possible that the Russians are
thinking longer term around a prisoner
swap that has happened in the past back
in December they swapped an American
basketball player called Brittany
Greiner who had been convicted on drugs
charges they swapped her for a notorious
arms trafficker called Victor boot he
was held by the Americans they did that
swap back in December that could be part
of the thinking here
but at the moment uh gershkovic trying
to he's trying to get alternative
detention Arrangements at the moment
this is not about the substance of those
charges I I think that he is he is
looking realistically he's looking at
spending a a long term a significant
period of time in in a Russian prison at
the moment
the woman in the center of the picture
now in blue that is Lynn Tracy she is
the U.S ambassador to Moscow I mean it's
pretty significant that she's actually
there in the courtroom isn't it
yes yes it is uh it is significant she
did have the opportunity to to see him
she was able to gain access to the
prison yesterday and she was able to
report that uh gershkovic was in was in
good spirits and uh gershkovic has also
been able to write to his parents uh
said he's been eating properly he's been
able to get some exercise he's also
writing as well
again you know this is it's significant
because it's so rare he is a journalist
for an established newspaper The Wall
Street Journal they have Bureau all over
the world he was hired just before the
invasion of Ukraine uh began prior to
that he'd been working to an English
language publication in Moscow the
Moscow times he's an experienced
journalist he speaks Russian so he would
have been aware of some of the risks and
dangers of working in Russia but
obviously significant concerns now both
for his family for the U.S government as
well who who see him as a political
prisoner
okay John thanks for that
and we will have more on that story
throughout the morning here on Sky News
very very important uh developing story
there now
what are the following have in common
Wakefield trinities Bellevue Stadium the
Sandwell Aquatics Center in smethwick
and shepparton film studios in Surrey
well the answer is all of them contain
structural steel that was supplied by
Billington Holdings the barnsley-based
structural steel and construction safety
solution specialist today it reported a
full year pre-tax profit of 5.8 million
pounds on an underlying basis that was
up from 1.3 million pounds in 2021 will
joining me now from barnsley's
billington's Chief Executive Mark Smith
Mark very good morning to you clearly
you've had a strong year what are you
seeing in the structural steel market
right now
well thank you uh good morning yeah
we've we've quite bullied by the results
last year
it was challenging for a start H2 really
was beset with
the impact from Ukraine uh following but
um recovered well uh during
um
H1 and the volumes have picked up
certainly in certain sectors
um during which a remain Mark can be
strong and so we're seeing then recovery
through um
10 20
maintained and just into
so these sectors which we're specialist
in supplying to and we noticed you were
talking about Ai and data centers
we're A supplier in the data center
Market
at least we've got a number projects
then that run into 23 through its 24
as well as supplying into energy from
waste sectors as well so these these
markets are and providing a good
on the back of good results we see
that continuing into 20
. good to hear I mean you've obviously
been grappling with inflation not only
elevated energy costs but also some of
the raw materials that go into making
steel as well are you seeing those
pressures starting to Abate now
um there's still
um price escalation has been a concern
um we are seeing some stabilization of
steel prices at the moment
and the energy costs for most we've seen
Peak we've been quite fortunate in so
much called it unfortunate and lucky we
managed to fix energy costs
beginning 22 so we've missed a major
Peak and we're happy to see those on the
side
more stabilization gives us a a better
opportunity going forward so energy
costs are concerned particularly as they
have been for the steel manufacturers so
in terms of Steel Supply
um that seems to be more equalized and
following the Ukraine issues where we
were having difficulty with certain
elements of Steel Supply seems to a
equalized as well and so again the
future looks
at that
Mark you buy from all of the major steel
producers in the UK How concerned should
people be about the future of steel
production in this country
and they've had pressures it's it's it's
no mystery and but we're confident that
money and investment now is being made
by our major steel producer British
steel we are a major customer at
register as well as
other European World producers
but we're a big supporter we are bullied
by the fact that Supply is is now robust
um we're seeing good investment and so
again more positive
now you also have a very fast growing
division called hordit which is
environmental hoardings what's driving
growth there
um I think it's fair to say yes the
construction Market has has seen a good
good view and they
um try
contractors
wounding residential as well which
buildings and structures tends to stay
large and out of but
itself is a very you know to be
environmentally sound product
um and so really I think their growth
has been down on the popularity and the
good service provided by audit all right
Mark I know it's a busy day for your
results day we do appreciate you
spending the time to speak to us today
thank you
thank you very much
that's it for me this morning there's
much more on the Sky News Mobile app and
on the website with reporting commentary
and Analysis from our business team
there's a piece from me right now
they're on my interview yesterday with
Brian Armstrong from coinbase do have a
look at that if you can well there's
much more to come after this short break
Jane suckers going to be in the chair
and we will have all the latest for you
for that court hearing from The Wall
Street Journal reporter Evan gershkovic
I'll see you tomorrow cheerio
[Music]